commencer
dans notre pays les autorités
n'ont pas du tout soutenu les gens les gens
commencent à penser d'une
autre manière
envoyé pour prendre le pouvoir
nous avons perdu la liberté
assange a dit que vous vivez comme une union soviétique
beaucoup de gens croient et nos parents
voulaient que cette union soviétique soit le meilleur
moment pour eux
dix ans de congé deviennent meilleurs
mais ce n'est pas lukaszenki juste la
russie reçoit beaucoup d'argent et dolores
obtenir de l'argent aussi
notre salaire vers le bas course du texas
chaque année tous les gars de mon usine
doivent travailler une heure de travail travail officiel
deuxième monde
certains veulent réparer des voitures quelqu'un paie
une
facture à quelqu'un nous ne pouvons pas gagner d'argent au
même endroit
[Musique]
quand il a changé la constitution  et 24
majorité ont soutenu kasanka 2010 années
où beaucoup de candidats ont essayé de jouer
dans chaque
superpuissance majoritaire à kashanka
maintenant une situation différente je ne connais pas
une seule personne qui prendrait
des questions votantes
[Musique]
euh
toi